RUM RUM
RUM Sorry, I'm so tight.
RUM RUM Oh, dad's getting into it too.
He's like, yeah, RUM I'm so tight.
We lost it.
Oh shit, why is that on?
How did I fix that?
I'm sorry, guys.
I don't know what happened to me.
I fucking, I guess I just, I just died for a second there.
I was in the REM minds.
I actually did not play more deadlock after the stream.
I did work stuff and then I just passed.
I think I was just catching up on all my REM sleep.
Get it?
And it was just catching up on all the sleep.
My sleep schedule is so fucked up.
On all the sleep that I missed out from playing REM.
So, basically, I took that.
Oh, yeah.
So, my manager was like, she's not waking up.
I'm going to push her.
He, like, messaged me, like, not responding.
She's not going to wake up and push the street for it.
And he was right.
And I was just like, but then I was like, oh, why is it?
one third he had no faith in me he had no faith in me he
pushed it at one 30 instead of one he gave me an hour
instead of 30 that no faith no i came back just in time well
30 minutes late but just in time all right so the dad
incident so there was 20 minutes left till stream it was a
15 minutes
Obviously, I took that to the dog park because it's the
fastest he pees and poop if there's no dogs there So it's
always a 50-50 and I really and the dog park was this was
actually like closer than like going To like his usual spot
It's just closer and I could go there inside the building
like you go like like access it via inside the building So I
went with that and it's always a 50-50 gamble because he
does it really really fast There's nobody there He's like
Peep poop done So I took that gavel Because if I go to If I
go to his usual place It takes him much Well it doesn't even
take It takes him Like it's fast too But then it's longer to
get there So I was just like I don't really want to walk too
far Anyway so I was there And He was doing it We got there
Instantly peas Instantly fucking does it And I was like
Yippie And then he starts sniffing around, trying to find
the spot for pooping.
And then, okay, a corgi came in first, so it wasn't like the
same dog yet.
So another dog came in, and he was like, oh, okay.
But then he still, he didn't really care about the corgi.
He doesn't give a fuck about corgis.
He sees them as very annoying.
Like, I think corgis are more friendly in terms of, like,
towards, like, not friendly, but more so, like, more want to
interact with other dogs.
And he does not care.
every time a corgi approaches him he does not give a fuck he
ignores him he actually like fucking turns his head away
like do not talk to me um you might be long but we're not
same dog like we are not the same you are long yes but we
are not the same in fact i might be better than you like he
was discriminating that's for sure uh my is my dog racist
maybe He may or may not be racist.
I can't tell you.
I don't know if he's just uninterested or he might just be
very racist.
I don't know.
I don't know about dog racism.
So, anyway.
Anyway, so he was still sniffing around.
And, and, um, and then, and then same dog appeared, another
wiener dog.
And then dad was very interested.
He was like, same dog.
Same dog.
It's like, same hat.
Same hat.
and then so he went straight to the other dog and you know
the other dog was like oh same dog but he was like not as
interested as dad he's like okay same dog yeah like but yes
i i 100 percent lost uh lost the gamba lost the gacha the 50
50 of whether or not dogs will be there but then i hit the i
hit the mother load not only was there other dogs there
there was the same dog i've never i've barely ever seen
another wiener dog by the way at this park i think like this
is the third time i've seen another wiener dog at this park
so it was like so it was like i actually hit like the um the
jackpot of unluckiness uh the ssr same dog wiener same
wiener dog uh yeah it's like seeing a shiny um surprisingly
there's not a lot weiner dogs here so anyway um anyway so
the other dog was actually sort of like two he's sorry i
found out i was a guy later uh because i thought maybe it
was also a female same dog because that was very interested
um but anyway the other dog was like like they smelled each
other and then he was the other dog was just like yeah yeah
all right and then dad kept trying to smell the butt But
then you tell that the other dog was uncomfortable and also
did not like that because they put their tail down.
You know, that's when you know if another dog put their tail
down, they're like, I don't want you to sniff my ass.
Like, I don't want you to like check me out.
Like, I do not give consent to this.
But then dad kept trying to sniff it.
And at one point, the other dog just sat down because they
were like, no.
Like, yeah, like, I do not fuck with this.
Like, but Dad, he couldn't get the message, which is a
little creepy, Dad.
It was very pushy about it.
He's like, I want to sniff your butt.
And the other dog's like, no, I don't get sent.
He's like, he's like, he's like,
I will sniff your butt.
and then it got to a point where at um he was just following
the other dog around because uh he has yeah it's a little
bit problematic that might be a little problematic guys uh
it might be a little problematic um it got to a point where
he was just following the other dog around i'm just like oh
my god i don't want my phone with me i don't know what time
it is i know that i'm not making it back.
I was just like, I know I'm not making it back.
I don't have my phone with me.
I know this is going to be a while.
This is going to take a while.
Um, Eddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That is the stranger danger in the park.
So it got to the point where, um, you know, he was following
the other dog around and then, um, he, you know, still
trying to sniff the other dog's butt.
And at one point he was like, that's it.
And then I, I, I, I, I, I could sort of tell and I was like,
no, don't do it.
Please don't do it.
I was just like, I, you know, like when you can tell your
dog is preparing mentally and like, he's just like, I'm
going to do it.
I'm like, oh no, is he going to, I mean, you can tell, you
see the signs.
You as an owner, you know the signs of when he wants to do
it.
But I had too much faith in my, in my dog.
I was like, my dad, my dog to not do it.
I was just like, maybe he won't.
You know, maybe don't embarrass me in front of this dog
park.
Dad, please don't, there's two people watch.
Please don't embarrass me.
And he's like, he's about to, all you tell him.
He's like 99% charged up.
And then he went to the back and then started mounting.
And I was like, no.
I'd like the other two owners, the other owner of the same
dog didn't even say anything.
He was like sitting in the bench watching and I was like,
no, like the moment he started to mount and yeah, and he got
off instantly.
I was like, no.
He was just like, same dog.
He's like, same dog, same dog.
Thank you, Mr. Rochette.
Thank you.
Dad loves other dogs almost as much as you love, Brad.
And by the way, the other dog is a guy, though, by the way.
He's like, gender doesn't matter to him.
Is my dog bisexual?
No, that is.
No, he may or may not, he may or may not be racist and bi.
I guess he's gay.
Apparently, they do that to establish dominance because he
doesn't do that to any other.
I've never seen him mount any other dog, by the way.
Like, I've never seen him try to, he's neutered.
He's been neutered at a very young age and, like, at the
appropriate age, by the way.
So, um, so, uh, I've never seen him actually, like, mount
another dog before.
Uh, so I, I apparently it's a dominance thing being like, we
might be the same dog, but I am the better same dog.
Like, he might be just thinking like, I'm, I'm you, but
better.
And he was trying to show them, he was trying to show him
how he, he's, he's more dominant than the other one of the
two like i'm gonna show you who's boss who's the top dog
yeah and then after that i left i was just like we're not
coming back here we're
he wants to show the other he wants to show the world that
he is the alpha weir dog he's like i'm you but i'm the alpha
uh but yes and then i left and now we're here so so that was
my morning i um so that was my morning today guys uh i had
to deal with my dog and finding out that he might be
potentially racist and by uh showed him who and might if
thank god he is a dog because i'm worried that he could be
on the list i oh yeah anyway life update not my life but
like corinne events update did you guys see la sara film um
la sara film collab with the newest Sarah film collab uh for
Overwatch and then I love how everyone because people were
like oh yeah so um this uh it was like Onron Demon Freya uh
who else I don't uh what was the what was the other DPS name
the newest DPS uh Overwatch I don't see her people play her
a lot so I always forget her What's the other DPS?
No, not, no, I'm not talking about Mizzou.
I'm leaving that last, of course.
For obvious reasons.
Um, uh, what was her name?
I never, I don't see her played a lot, so I always forget
her name.
Because I don't, like, on, I guess, uh, Dvon apparently is
being played a lot right now for meta, but I always forget
that DPS player's name.
Just because I, oh, Sierra.
Sorry, Sierra.
Okay, so on run.
demon freya and sierra and then the other two those are the
surprise picks is mazuki and mora i and everyone was like
mora and like this so like 60 to 70 year old uh grandma or
auntie being getting a lasera lasera film collab yeah yeah I
think I love, I love this tweet.
More Kevin Girl Pop 2.
He's like the chaperone.
She can be K-pop 2, guys.
Of course, of course.
It was just felt, I was just buried.
It's like, how do you do fellow kids, you know?
She is ag maxing it for real.
She's showing her, she's showing her stomach, guys.
Moor is in town.
She's looking for it.
The cougar is here.
Looking for the gums.
So this is also Mizuki's shirtless too.
Five idols and a manager.
Also the shirtless Mizuki.
He's looking at him.
Yeah, oh, you slut showing your entire chest like that.
so I thought that was I thought that was really funny I
thought like the the show more of Mizuki was pretty pretty
funny to see you um I just love that tweet I'm seeing more
at the concert um other than that what else what else can
you with internet update I mean maybe that's like internet
update okay so you're close-ups too uh let me show you guys
the close-ups of it they always do these by the way the
reason why la seraphim is always collabing with overwatch is
because they literally saved overwatch um an article was an
interview was released where uh the reason why they do a lot
of these collab like i think people didn't realize ever
since they did these collab skins um this was uh the la
seraphim started the collaboration trend of like you know
how they now they do a lot of collaboration skins with a
bunch of different ips and brands now um they this was what
started it the very first one because um at that time the
game was dying like there was like no hope like blizzard was
already like giving up hope uh with overwatch and then they
they did a seraphim skin collab and they said the Kiriko
skin sold the most of every skin combined.
Like every skin that they've ever released in the shop, in
the store, didn't reach the level of the Kiriko Laceraphim
collab.
And that's why Kiriko always gets skins now.
And they were seeing how like it was like a ginormous gap
between the first place and second place.
Like even with all the Mercy skins out there, skins um and
all even with all the mercy skins they've released um before
the Kiriko one Kiriko outsold all of them and it was like
the like it literally saved Overwatch the Kiriko skin
literally saved the game because of it and that's why um
that's why Kiriko always gets skins now and then that's why
um they they they do a lot of laserafin collabs because they
literally saved uh overwatch
they were like they were like oh shit like like wait this is
where the money is yeah it actually carried them financially
um let me say i could find the article i was like no way um
but it's like one of the directors of overwatch that was
talking about it and saying like how if it wasn't for um
legit uh they would have closed the servers for the game
like there was no reason they would like they would not like
have kept the game alive for this long it was because of
this collab that they made so much fucking money that they
were like we gotta keep doing this we gotta keep doing more
collaboration brad like collaboration skins because that's
where all the money is now uh it's not the it's not like the
the rank games or like the the game modes or anything like
is where it's at like yeah so it was just like we we got and
that's why kiriko has so many because they realized wait
people buy a lot of kiriko skins so they're like oh my god
this this she's the money maker she they found they found
the formula let's see let me uh selling the most i don't
know if i can find it was on twitter like when people were
talking about the article so i need to find it it was crazy
though yeah kiriko maize are literally keeping the lights on
at what out of now but back when the first collaboration was
announced um kiriko was financially helping overwatcher so
much and they were just like it's just a crazy gap between
like became the most successful skin when that collaboration
was released.
And I mean, if it works, it works.
Like it kept the game alive.
Yeah, they found the meta.
They figured it out.
They figured out the formula.
I thought it was, I think it was so surprising that it
wasn't Mercy that kept, you know, like, you know how it,
like it wasn't Mercy that, because, you know, Mercy was like
the OG skin seller, And even then, Mercy could not even
compete to how much skins Kiriko made for, like, how much
skins Kiriko sewed, which is mind-blowing to me as someone
that went through, like, how obsessive Mercy skins were.
Like, that blew my mind, because, like, at that time, Mercy
was, like, the number one queen of Overwatch when it comes
to, like, Mercy players would only play.
mercy um so like and they would buy all the skins and even
then kierko outsold them i think it's because like it wasn't
just mercy because like i guess it was because like it
wasn't just mercy players buying mercy skins it was like
everyone buying that kierko skin because like technically
kierko is played by everyone so um um so i i guess it's
because it wasn't just like specifically just mercy players
it was like everybody just bought that skin the Kiriko skin.
But you know, Masuki's skin, yeah, he's like, ooh, yeah.
He's like, I'm too sexy for that shirt.
Yeah, sexy for that shirt.
All right, what else?
What else did I wanna talk about?
There's another thing I wanna talk about.
I mean, look, oh yeah, the DLSS5 finally got released.
And people are, hold on, people are creating new analog
horrors of the, like, they were, like, putting DLSS 5 on top
of, like, non-realistic games.
And it looks absolutely terrifying.
It's so gross.
Yeah.
But, like, all right, so I initially thought it was, like,
apparently they passed it through several times.
at DLSS so that's why it looks like this but even then it
looks absolutely fucking terrifying let me show you for
those haven't seen it yet um yeah I don't think I got no
comment I don't think I need to explain further
yes dlss5 What is that guys it's realism guys it's taking
realism
Oh, you know what's funny?
Um, this is also this unrelated though uh I thought it was
real.
Oh, I just realized you're not on my screen.
I just realized that uh oh my gosh i forgot
i like blanked out there my mind instantly like no you don't
don't know what's funny oh i guess we'll never know what was
so funny guys i guess we'll never know but pretty much it
was like oh wait i remember now all right you know what's
funny um did you guys hear about the Yu-Gi-Oh tournament
that was going on, the Yu-Gi-Oh World Champions, that was
like around the same time as the Pokemon World, um, which is
weird.
I think it's weird that they put, they scheduled it on top
of each other.
I felt like that had to be like on purpose, like having both
of them on at the same time, just to see, like, just to
like, I guess measure their dicks or something.
Like it was like a, a dick swinging contest.
Like, I think that's weird that they're both on this at the
same time.
Um, uh anyway it was really funny well not it's sad it's a
little sad too uh it's a little sad and also like a little
funny um so one of the teams they got like top four or
something and right after they um the trophy by the way okay
so right after they won like the day after they won they got
top four in one of the yugioh categories they went they they
posted on twitter that they were selling the trophy and they
were selling like everything they got from the competition
and like oh my i thought i thought it was like oh my like
like day after but it's because it's because um it's because
uh the yugioh tournaments do not have monetary prizes uh so
like they only have physical prizes because i believe conami
right conami doesn't actually own the rights to yugioh
they're like a distributor um they they have like they just
have like like you know the uh they have an agreement with
the ip holder so they're not allowed to do cash prizes at
all and they can because if they do cash prizes like the
contract's broken and they don't have control of the IP.
They don't get to license the, have a license of the IP
anymore.
So they only have a license of the IP.
They don't actually own the IP.
And so one of the competitors literally got like the top
four and instantly went to sell the trophy.
They're like DM for offers and everything.
And they're like, oh, I have all of these if you guys want
it.
And because this is like the only way for them to make
money.
And they traveled all the way to Japan too, just
understandable um because they're not they're like from
where they from uh i don't know what teams they're from
they're from uh they're from morocco and they're like yeah i
just want to make i just want to make money like i guess
like you know he knows what yeah he knows like you know what
he wants to do um he won but he just he's just there he
needs the money you know um there it's no other way to make
money off of this um other than just other than just like
you know selling the stuff he's won but like i will say this
trophy is fucking sick as hell like you can't like i i
low-key i was like i'm i almost dmed him i was like holy
shit this goes hard
shit yeah i was just like this trophy goes fucking hard
though like i i i feel like i never post about it because
they're like i can't believe you bought someone's trophy
like it's like stolen valor but i'm like bro this shit goes
so hard though
i know right i was like ah but it's and valor with some guys
random trophy but like i was just like holy bro this is so
fucking cool it's purchased by valor um eating thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you uh jessica thank you for
super chat thank you thank you my dog is potentially racist
and binding mountain homie what time to open a stream hi
toky thank you for the super chat jessica thank you thank
you golden thank you super chat thank you thank you do it
will look good next to the box thank you thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you i mean like both like it's
literally like i thought it was i saw this picture of the
trophy earlier before the tournament and i thought it was um
i thought it was just for like the world champion but then i
didn't realize like top you each each person in top four
gets uh one of these and i was like oh my wait guys it was
like three days ago i i think like he's already he might
have already sold it guys i don't know should i like dm him
just to gauge how much he sold it for like and i put my own
name at the bottom be like dokey bird world semi-final I'm
tempted to gauge just to, I don't know if I'll buy it, but
like, I want to know how much it went for.
I'm like, check if you still ask, no, don't keep purchase
the value.
Right on it as a sharpie.
Guys, I'm going to ask, I'll be like, hey, are you still
selling?
Are you still selling?
selling in the trophy or it was it or was it already is oh i
wrote song
i'm not gonna buy i just want to know how much i okay we'll
see how much it cost we're gonna see how much it costs
that's sick as hell come on guys guys come Fine, you admit
that is actually a stat trophy is actually, I wish they did
do monetary prizes as well because ARP, thank you for the
super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, Doki
Pie is a trophy or against one elsewhere, Doki is the new
Yu-Gi-Oh champion now, Doki becomes the queen of games,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
anime uh we gotta return it guys to me
if they had it's like if they had monte press and the trophy
then it like it may yeah but oh my god that is such that
isn't that's so pretty like i like okay what's the pokemon
world's trophy it's just so creative you know it's Like,
compared to the fucking Pokemon World's Trophy, they have
Pikachu on it, whatever.
Mine is an ancient tablet.
Ancient Egyptian tablet.
Like, Pikachu could never.
With the...
What was it called?
With the millennial puzzle.
Come on!
It looks like they dug it out of Egypt.
Look at that.
Like, all Pikachu could never.
Like, like, I, like, come on, if you look at the, if you
compare the two, if we compare the two, like, you could tell
Yu-Gi-Oh!
Ora-Farming with, you could tell that, like, Yu-Gi-Oh!
is Ora-Farming, like, an actual artifact that I dug up an
archaeological site.
It's no contest.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It's cute, but nowhere near close.
The Pikachu, the ancient Egyptian slab over Pikachu.
Curse of purchase value.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pokemon with a $5 on the show.
To be fair, Pokemon World does have monetary prizes.
So, like, it makes sense that Konami went all in on the
trophy.
itself just because they can't give money to people.
So, like, all the money lies on creating these slabs.
Ancient snab that may or may not be cursed or Pikachu.
Uh, but yeah, we'll see.
I'm pretty sure he's sold already.
It was like three days.
I was tempted to, like, DM him.
Um, right when I saw the tweet, which was, like, exactly the
day, um, Um, oh my god, some people are still messing up,
messing with DLSS.
Okay, wait, look at this new DLSS 5.
Picture for, this is for Dragon Quest, by the way.
What stopped me because of stolen Valor, that's why.
I was like, can I even, like, show this on stream?
Like, can I even, like, because I was like, oh, it's obvious
it's going to be stolen Valor.
And people would be like, what the fuck do you?
But now that I have your approval that you guys all see how
sick as fuck that trophy is, now I'll DM him being like,
hey, how much does it cost?
Like, now that you guys understand that it's sick as hell, I
don't feel self-conscious now about DMing.
Like, that's Dragon Quest.
That's Wagon Quest.
He looks like, yeah, I was gonna say, he looks like Chucky.
That's DLSS 5, Thwagon Quest.
America.
Fuck yeah.
You know, I was, that was like one of the songs I thought
about singing at the dokey dokey rewind time.
And then I was like, maybe I should pick an actual real
song.
Fuck, because I was like in America.
So I thought it would be funny because...
No, I thought it would be funny because my concert would be
at July 4th.
So I'd be like, oh, maybe I should sing America.
Fuck yeah.
I thought about just the fact, just because it was July 4th.
what it could have been uh it would have been really funny
it would have hey guys i got yugioh world champion trophy
ain't it cool what the fuck is a cool tune thank you for the
super chat feel good thank you thank you all right all right
that's enough of internet update today we're gonna be
playing what's it called i didn't grow up with this game so
but i know a lot of you guys did and uh have a lot of fun
memories of this game so i was like oh let's try it out
insane aquarium i've never played this game before um i know
there are is a lot it's just fishes in an aquarium that's
all that's my only knowledge about this game i have no other
context or like uh background info about what this game is
so i'm going in blind fully blind i legit know nothing about
it So, let's check it out.
Let's see.
Let me...
Ooh.
I need to make sure I snapshot my audio settings for
Deadlock before I...
Whoa!
Let me capture the Deadlock audio settings before we go in.
Deadlock.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Did I make my...
Well, did my, not me, did my manager make about in members'
waiting room yet?
I was like, hmm, did I?
Oh, silly me, Doki.
You mean your manager?
I'll wait.
No, he went offline.
He went to bed.
Guys, all right, before I do, let me make the waiting room.
Let me make the waiting room for tonight's members' stream.
Let's see.
Oh, it's because I forgot to forward.
it to a series of unfortunate events guys i forgot to
forward the stream thumbnail to them all right all right
before we go let me make the waiting room for members real
quick i forgot something today no surely uh surely i did it
not even myself uh it's at six okay give me a sec i'm just
making the members waiting room for tonight um we're gonna
dokeford dokeford university will be the very best i hope i
hope our dokeford students have been grinding the leader
boards the dean's coming back i hope they're grinding the
leader boards right now
hmm all right let's see at 6 p.m
very professional by the way incredibly professional i think
it's just the post rem
it's just because it's it's i i'm streaming after my after
my rem addiction which i'm so disoriented right now i i'm so
disoriented right after my post rem addiction okay and then
i remember stream is up waiting room is up and then i'll
make the uh the community post real quick guys we're all
don't worry we're almost there I put my scuba goggles for
this, my snorkeling goggles for this very moment.
Oh, God, there we go.
Back with more power.
How many weeks do you have left?
You have two weeks left of the server.
I think, yeah, of the server.
What, two weeks left of the server?
Uh...
Let's see.
And then I have to tweet it out.
Tweet out the membership stream.
Membership stream.
Or just membership.
Membership.
Training room is here.
Uh...
more more power with the goons and maybe we'll maybe we'll
check out the sloppy sister server guys I finally finally
lowered the egg hatching time guys I finally remember after
a month I finally remembered to lower it it only took me one
month Oh, yeah, I've done that for an entire month.
I was like, oh, yeah, I finally did it last night.
I was like, oh, yeah, okay, I'll do it now.
Better late than never.
Two weeks left of the server, so let's check out today's
Dragon.
progress let's see uh and then boop
all right we're good to go we are good to go all right now
insane aquarium uh boop there you go We have sound guy the
sound guy live.
Well, I'll lower it just in case because I don't know Oh my
god.
Oh pop cap made this Dokey.
Oh, wait is this oh, is this one of those games that can't
be game captured?
Yeah, this looks like a game that can't Wait, let's Let me
see All right, is this a game that can't be game captured
and I have to do Oh, I have to do Window capture It's an old
game.
It makes sense.
No, it can be, but I have to do window capture.
Which sometimes I don't like to do.
Because window capture is a little bit more riskier.
Alright, let's see.
I don't know.
I don't.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
It doesn't...
Fine, it doesn't know where the game is.
Wait, why does it not know?
Should I do, should I do, like, not full screen?
Why do you not see the existence of this game?
When the catcher was like, I don't see it.
What do you mean you don't see it?
It's right there.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, this sees it.
All right, okay, we got it.
all right full screen please hello oh no no okay i gotta
reboot this didn't want to full screen it all right this
should work now now that i full screen it give me a sec i
need to full screen this game all right there we go it was
like not registering full screen I don't know what game
you're talking about.
All right.
Doki fish.
That's me.
Well, I've never played this game before, so I don't know.
All right.
Here are the options.
Sound guy.
If sound guy's alive.
If sound.
Sound guy.
I hope you're alive right now.
But we're going to start our adventure.
Click on the tank to drop food for...
Oh my god.
What?
Why are aliens trying to take my quiz?
Like, don't you want to just take over the world?
It's just a fucking $5 aquarium.
That fish look like they cost me 50 cents.
Like, all three pieces of egg to advance the level and gain
a new pet.
Gotta start somewhere.
Alright, let me...
there you go eat my eat my food little fishies eat my food
this is the insane of aquarium not some not a regular
aquarium dokey God right learn to read oh my god can you are
these fishies blind but look behind you use your noses oh my
I can only do one at a time.
Wait, that's worse.
They eat each other.
If you make a fish too big, oh, wait, I have to continuously
feed them.
Or they die.
I just saw it.
He was like, great.
Come on.
Get big for me, little guys.
Oh, please eat it.
I don't want you to die.
Please, it's right in front of me.
No, he can't see.
He has a special disease.
Oh,
this is bad.
I'm a very bad fish.
Guys, every time I've owned a fish, they've died.
Like, you don't live too long.
I don't know.
Same with plants.
I just, I don't know how to take care of plants and fish.
I don't know.
I swear to God, it's...
Okay, give me a second.
I swear to God, it's not...
I swear to God, it's not on purpose.
They just happened to die.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to like move.
I can't even move the game.
Oh my god.
I want to move the game to a little to a left.
But I can't.
Because every time I tap out.
The game disappears.
They have a chance.
They forget to live.
I can't even move the game screen.
I'm the OBS.
If I think it just disappears.
It's like, if I don't look at it, it's the game even real.
Is it?
Oh my god, please eat.
Please eat.
Please, it's right in front of you.
Oh, why did I get another fish?
I could barely take care of one, apparently.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This is so stressful.
place is literally right in front of you just eat it oh my
god at least you're pooping money out
oh my god no you're getting old and you're losing your
eyesight
okay oh my god this is too stressed so this is why i can't
own fish
guys I could barely take care of one oh my god please why do
you have such big eyes you can't even see okay all right
nice like a snail stinky roams around uh the bomber tank
catching any coins you may have missed okay god okay there
you go don't worry about that what happened to my other fish
they just died yeah just you know how like parents where
they don't want to tell kids are fishes my parents didn't do
that they made sure my fish died they they made sure to tell
me my fish died but like some parents um some parents they
would do the thing where um where they don't want to let
their kids know about death so they'll uh they'll just buy
new fishes to replace the other fish The vicious alien's
mouth.
What laser weapon?
Where?
Oh, shit!
Alright.
Everything's fine.
Alright, eat it.
Yeah.
There's the laser.
But, you know, I...
I've seen a lot of dead fish.
They've made sure I failed to take care of an animal.
I don't know!
I just don't know.
Upgrade food quality.
Come on, come on.
This is not expensive food and you're not going to eat it.
Oh my god.
Look behind you.
Look behind.
What I don't understand though, I don't understand like the,
you know, like the type of, you know, the type of...
there's like goldfish breeding and oh he's so hungry he's so
hungry well i'm trying to feed you please eat it please okay
eat this eat this it's right here it's right here i'm
purposely putting it in front of you all right we'll get the
quality up
all right oh i'm already so stressed out oh i have meds take
your meds take your meds Oh, to push it down or shoot its
tail to deflect it.
Why?
I guess to like, oh, I guess to make sure they don't touch
my fish.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, eat it.
Please eat it.
Don't touch my fish.
Do not touch him.
Okay.
Oh, you're so stupid.
But like, you know how there's like specific goldfish
breeding where, um, well, do I just feed them when they're
hungry?
Oh, yeah, fuck it.
I'm just gonna feed them when you're hungry.
You don't deserve this.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you're taking your meds.
Take your meds.
Grave.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, whoa.
Whoa.
It's okay.
You brought down a lot more.
All right.
Nice.
I'll bring it down a lot more.
Um, and then there's like, I used to watch like YouTube
short and then like, oh my gosh.
It's like, if you get like the types of fish, goldfish, with
the giant, like, tumor heads.
Like, oh, just let them starve a little.
Thank you.
Thank you for...
Like, that's the type of advice you'd like to see for when
it comes to taking care of.
Just, you know, make them starve a little so they're one and
more.
But, and then you have to, like, apparently you have to
routinely, like, trim.
their heads or they'll go blind and die like i was like i oh
my god like what you have to trim their tumors to make sure
it doesn't cover their entire face so they can live
comfortably then why breed them like that why select and
breed them to have the giant tumor heads like there
you go it's just skin flaps it's like extra skin on the
heads where it covers the eyes all right we're almost we're
almost done but um oh i could have bought more fish that's
all right i got the egg yeah that you can click on you got
the i don't have to feed them right is it just i just have
to oh shit oh shaley's look down all right this is a pretty
insane feel pain but like you don't really know you know
like you can't really tell when because like fishes don't
really can't really speak you know they don't really make
noises they just they're like pop pop pop all right so like
i feel like they just yeah so it's like you can't really
tell if like trimming the little skin flaps actually like is
bad or like it hurts them or not well they like grip the
fish they like they can't really run away when you pick them
up and take them out of the aquarium oh my god oh my god he
missed it are you blind okay i don't know if it's a good
idea to have like five of them right off the bat when they
could all, what if they all just starve?
Oh, like, like right now, they all just starve together.
No.
Oh my gosh.
Where is it?
Oh, don't do not starve!
Oh, God.
Okay.
I didn't realize I can't feed them when the alien shows up.
That's a little inconvenient for me.
Alright, okay, we're gonna keep this amount of fish because
I don't, I don't have any more if five of them go hungry i'm
oh they're all going hungry at the same time i do not like
this i oh i have to click on the die i'm sorry i thought my
snail was gonna click it for me i didn't realize he could
only see money oh come on
oh there we go It's dropping a ton of food at the start.
Okay, there you go.
Kind of, boy.
Is he going to eat my fish?
Like, what the fuck is he going to do?
I guess...
Okay, now that I have two, I feel more comfortable putting
more fish in here.
Yeah, there you go.
Ah!
No!
See, this is why you don't name your fish.
He died so fast!
What did he die?
He died so...
You guys saw it, right?
He died so fast!
Okay, I'll bring another one in.
It was like, I looked away for one second.
For one second.
Oh, God.
Eat.
Okay, we'll grab three just in case.
Just in case.
I'm already getting there's already too many things going.
Oh, if I...
Okay.
Just eat.
I didn't realize that the coins disappeared.
I thought my...
I thought you've been picking up my coins!
How much money have I been losing?
Why is my investments?
I thought I invested in you getting everything!
Why are you saying you haven't been picking my coins?
Maybe I'll eat one of these.
Oh my god.
What's the point of having you in my thing if you don't
even...
Okay, so yeah, in this case, he's doing his best.
Okay, what does he do?
Does he eat all my fish?
Oh, I'm only...
Looks like he's about to eat them.
Okay.
Okay, I can't even fucking trust you anymore.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, how are you dying?
How are you dying?
What do you eat?
What do you...
He's gonna die.
He only eats a small fish!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll try again.
Here we go.
We'll have this guy chilling in here.
Oh my god.
How is I supposed to know?
Okay, eat him.
Eat him.
That's right.
Okay.
Holy shit, thank you.
Aurora effect for playing a game.
Thank you.
Alright.
okay i'll send one in just in case i'm so stressed out oh my
god did not mean to upgrade that i did not mean to upgrade
that i'm so stressed out right now this aquarium is pretty
insane some might say it's an insane aquarium oh my i'm
gonna throw all of this in just in case and then this tanya
just eat him
I do not fuck with this.
I...
Super good.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, we're gonna grab an egg.
The worst part is the updates don't like...
Okay, one of you will eat this, right?
Stop playing video games on my stream!
Stop!
Oh my god!
Okay.
We just need one more.
So another fish, and I don't know if he's hungry, but just
here's a little meal for you.
Alright, poop the diamond.
We're good to go.
Oh, God.
Eat, eat, eat.
Okay.
Alright, they ate.
I have enough.
Alright, what do I have?
It's Cheetah Swordfish.
Helps you by...
Oh my gosh, who even... I don't even need him.
Not gonna lie, I legit don't need him.
I actually don't need him.
I have the Super Strike.
The alien dies after I look at him.
Alright, eat.
Eat.
guys I thought this was a relaxing idle game I oh my god I
didn't realize what I oh wait blaze it I thought this was
gonna be a relaxing idle game guys I I didn't realize how
please eat it please please don't be stupid it's right there
okay I'll never I'll buy another one.
I think I can invest in another one.
I think I can micro this.
It's like playing Starcraft, guys.
Just click.
Don't die.
It's underneath you.
Don't be stupid.
I didn't raise those stupid fishes.
Alright, we're fine.
Doki has insane in the title.
Yeah, but I was like, how insane can it be, you know?
Holy shit.
It has so much HP.
Oh, my God.
I'm not expecting to have that much HP.
I don't trust my snails anymore.
Like, I don't trust my snail to do a good job.
It's like aim training.
This is my aim trainer, guys.
I'm literally aim training right now.
Don't let it's like, don't let it touch the floor.
I'll find this, and then...
I'm gonna try and get all these I'm gonna try and get all
these fishes to be big and strong by another guppy honestly
and another one and another one and then we'll raise all of
these guys okay before we send in the carnivores be nice to
the snail what do I pay you for what do I pay the snail for
Yeah.
Oh, you're gonna pick the meds and you're not gonna pick up
the coins.
I can buy one more.
Just for fun.
Oh, God.
They are all hungry at the same time.
That is not good.
Stop playing video games!
I swear to God, I've never turned off that setting, but I
might have to at this point.
Alright, there we go.
Okay.
oh my imagine playing video games all i'm saying is the baby
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it's
it become big and strong become big and strong for daddy oh
god eat him eat him eat him he's right there i swear to i
could die right in front of him
I...
Alright.
We're all good to go.
I'm gonna put a guppy in here just in case.
Man, you're such a cool streamer.
Advertise small streamers aren't...
Oh!
Dog!
Give me a sec!
I'm out!
There's two.
My fishes are hungry.
I can't read yet.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, I bet him just for him to die like that.
Okay, I'm gonna put some food out just in case.
Okay.
Everything's fine.
There you go, he died very, very fast.
You know what?
Two carnivores.
all right nice two carnivores and just buy guppies whenever
oh just
put one in here just oh just eat eat you're so hungry eat
here here's another one just in case i don't know if he ate
or anything eat them just eat them i don't care just just
eat them nice all right
all right dude that's a food cost me food i I can't tell.
I've been so stressed out.
I...
I can't tell.
Ah, eat!
Eat!
It's right here!
Okay.
It's fine.
You know, I will send two guppies in there.
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh, I didn't realize there was a pearl.
I'm looking at 20 different things on my screen.
I can't pause this.
I'm in the raid.
All right.
Prank, Pranko.
Okay.
You can tell it was the game made during the yield.
Pranko.
Where's this game?
I forget.
Pranko's a mama fish.
Okay.
What a name.
You can tell like when games used to be old.
Have you guys seen, oh my god, have you guys seen that
Ashton Kutcher interview back then?
Uh, where he was, I don't remember when he was talking, you
could tell like, you tell it did not age well.
But what people, like, you tell, like, if he said that now,
it would be, would have been canceled.
So, how do you tell when things are, like, a little bit
dated?
Yeah, I was like, whoa, he said, whoa.
What?
No, what?
I just, I don't know.
I don't know if you can just Google Ashton Kutcher
interview, but like, wow, you tell what things do not age
well.
The Prango Hubs populate your tank by giving birth to new
baby.
Oh, nice.
Okay, so I don't have to, um, I don't have to, like, buy
fish now.
Um, find a dirty mommy ASMR.
I've been praying for stop playing video games.
Yeah.
Uh, God, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Man, you're such a cool streamer advertised smaller gamers
on stream on Steam for free like that.
Thank you.
I wish I could move the game a little more to the left.
That's all I want.
I just want to move the game a little to the left, but I
can't because the game just... Oh, I get to choose it.
I'm not taking Stinkies.
You are useless.
Yeah.
Wait, actually, I have to take you because itchy is even
more useless.
never mind he was even more useless
all right bum bum bum i understand now oh my god she's a bug
she's in labor she's a labor we need a doctor right now oh
shit okay she's doing water natural water birth by the way
can i tell you guys this i recently found you know like what
was it called epidermal Is that, you know, like the, when
moms give birth, they're given like a little, uh,
anesthesia, like, not anesthesia, but, like, a pain
reliever, so it doesn't hurt as much.
I thought it was, like, a needle, like, you know, like an IV
needle or some shit, but it goes into your fucking spine.
The epidural, yeah.
An epidural, do you know the epidural goes into your fucking
spine?
It's, like, deep into your goddamn spine for it to work?
Like, oh, no, he's gonna die.
Yeah, because it's blocking your nerve.
I thought it was, like, an IV bag thing.
Like, like, it's just, like, a needle in your arm.
I didn't realize it fucking goes straight into your spine to
block.
Oh, God, you put out another baby.
Like, the mission is to block the...
See, I'm doing what...
I'm doing what Itchy was doing, but more efficiently.
Like, it...
Yeah, it's a giant-ass needle, too.
See, that's why she's doing a natural water birth.
No needle in her spot.
If she wishes, she can do that.
Oh, my God.
Pooped another.
He actually is pooping another baby.
Just buy it.
Okay, this might be a really bad idea.
I don't have a lot of food.
This could have been a bad idea.
idea I just spam 20 at the same time okay I couldn't buy
another one right now this actually would be very helpful
and I'll get higher quality food so they'll starve less and
then there you go I want to buy the high quality food so
they'll get get four and now buy another one.
Am I spending money on these food?
I don't, I can't tell.
Let me see.
Uh, I legit can't tell right.
Okay, I am.
It's five dollars.
Oh shit.
Okay.
So you better be grabbing this cash because I was trying to
figure out if I'm spending money or not.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I should have got itchy.
Oh, I cheat.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize they spotted more.
If they can't even fucking take over an aquarium, why even
try?
Like, get off of planet Earth at this point.
Like, you can find an easier planet.
This might not even be worth it in the end.
Okay, nice.
Alright, well, at least, like, whenever she poops out a
baby, it'll go straight into the piranha's mouth.
Oh, God.
it's just off fishes on my screen it's just off fishes on my
screen okay let me put one in here just in case i don't know
okay it's fine no did i go no i didn't get it oh god oh god
there you go okay you eat him you eat him his existence is
to be eaten
okay that's his entire purpose It's om-yom-yom-yom-yom-yom.
Eat em.
I need to put all of this in here.
There's just one guy there.
That's fine.
Bro.
Alright, nice.
Alright, we're good to go.
Everything is fine.
And then we got...
We'll grab another piranha.
all right come on come on mommy poop another one you know
you what what how did he die so oh my god how did he die so
fast i don't understand how long was he gonna how long was
he green how long was he green oh
my god he was hiding why would you hide yourself behind Oh,
there you go.
Okay, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'll just buy another one.
Everything is okay.
Oh, I should have saved that.
I should have saved that.
But I'm so confused!
Buy more baby guppies just in case.
We're preloading.
We're pre-gaming.
Pre-gaming guppies.
Oh my god.
I'm going to put a bunch right now.
Just in case they start starving.
all right good we pre-gamed in time and then i'll pre-game
some more fishes here just in case they get a little hungry
all right all right here you go
all right we're so close i'll pre-game pre-gaming
here you go everything is fine Everything is so fine.
He hatched another one.
Zorf gives you a hand in helping keeping your fish.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we might need this.
Clear as many shells as you can.
How do I...
Oh, I should...
That is easy.
Just keep clicking.
There you go.
Bam!
181.
I'm aim-labbing.
Duck, thank you.
Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you.
The real boss is the constant passage of time and depth as I
consume all.
Thank you, but Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, should I lower the volume?
Okay, I'm lowering the volume a little bit more.
Well, actually, I don't know if...
I don't know if you said that before or after I did.
Oh, for 20,000.
Do I have 20,000?
Oh.
Guys, I'm 781.
Do you think I'm close?
Oh my, that's it.
I'm fucking making sure I'm fucking closing that setting.
I don't close that setting.
Okay, account details.
All right.
Notifications.
I do not.
Let's see.
I've received an invite.
Where is the Seam family?
Where is my friend's list notification?
Where is...
That's it.
I already adjusted it.
Well, I adjusted it a little bit more.
I mean, I need to figure this out, guys.
Guys, I need to figure this out.
I'm trying to figure out how to...
I am invisible.
I need to figure out how to fucking change the friends that
I don't have so I don't see people what they're playing I'm
trying to figure out how to do that How do you do that
Alright there we go Friends Um Does it not tell you Are you
not allowed to Sign out chat or sign out How do I sign out?
Oh sign out there you go Offline Alright there you go okay
I'll grab these actually we don't need stinky anymore we'll
grab Prego, Nico and Zorf alright guys oh that's how you
feel oh he poops out food his poop is food it's like it's
like when you eat like bird saliva his poop is food
if it's not food where does it come from huh think about
that
if it's not food where is the food coming from oh time to
poop a baby natural water burp Some species can store, fun
fact, but you know, like some species, they can just, it's
just one and done.
Um, like the female can just have sex one time and it'll
store up all the sperm and it'll just keep making babies off
of that one session.
Like, did you guys know that?
I think that's like, like most, a lot of insects are like
that.
Yeah.
And it'll just make babies off of that one time that they
had, they banned.
Oh shit, feed this fish!
Feed him!
He's like, I want these fishes to earn their food.
I...
They must earn their meal.
What is star potion?
Yeah, ants are like that.
That's why like male ants, they only meet them one time and
then after they bang they die and they don't need to make
they don't even make another male ant after that their
entire purpose is just to bang the queen at one time and the
queen at stores all all the data and then she's done what is
a star potion oh my god
i think i know what a star potion is Guys, I think I figured
it out.
I didn't know I would kill them!
Oh, it makes them drop stars.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, it needs to be a fully grown fish.
Oh, I see.
I'll try one more time.
So is it gonna...
Oh, there you go.
Oh, you make moves to style.
That's cute.
Oh!
Okay, that's helpful.
Let me try and eat this.
Okay.
I gotta make sure I don't fucking explode another one.
Is he fully grown?
Okay, okay, I was gonna say.
Okay, I got scared.
I thought...
Okay.
I thought I was gonna do something bad.
Again.
Okay, grab this guy.
Might eat it.
Eat it.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, what?
I'm so stressed out.
Let me add one more.
Male angler fish dissolves into the female.
Oh, I know that.
Setup reproductive organs and nothing more next lesson
ducks.
Thank you the super chat skill I'm doing you.
Thank you dark.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Thank you today's thought humanity dogs have been
close for hundreds of thousands of years and it wasn't until
at least 1886 that we changed dogs by allowing them to stick
their heads out on the car window Thank you, let's super
chat dark.
Thank you.
Thank you Glad you're slowly through your tank collecting
any coins.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
That's right.
Stinky you're out of the job We have collide.
I don't need collide though we'll have these two you're
still you two are still out of the job I I my FPS reflexes
still do more than Clyde and stinky all I need is my feeders
and money and Prego all right whoops that's right swim for
your food swim all right another fish in the tank more
fishes you got poop this leg go back up go back up I need to
swim up but we'll put two more in there I'm sure This is not
gonna fuck me over a lot of these fishes in here.
Oh nice
What's a star catcher
All right, they should be fed a little longer now Oops Okay,
she doesn't get pregnant or she doesn't give birth fast
enough Come on you're fishes you're supposed to like why are
you pooping one at a time.
Oh shit Oh,
not these guys.
I think my guy starts feeding them when they're hungry.
Wait!
What happened to them?
Wait, they all died.
Wait, they start killing now?
What?
Come on, my fish!
Why did you swim closer?
Oh, this is bad.
that's so bad they always did i didn't even notice it stop
being so come on swim back up swim into the surface swim to
the surface i didn't even notice i didn't even actually
notice i don't know what this does he's just gonna be
chilling okay oh and keep eating keep eating I didn't notice
there were so many fishes in my team oh no oh no
you were right oh my fishies oh
I should have kept itchy I should have kept him in there
no why didn't you take my little potions oh he's sick he's
so sick I'm so stressed.
Okay, buy this.
Oh, I want to give a star, but they need them to eat it.
Come on, no, no, no, you fucking stupid fish!
Oh no, oh no.
I was strong and lasered up.
Get in the corner.
It's okay.
Eat it, eat it.
Yes!
I got the strat.
So how do I do the star?
Guys, I keep...
Okay, I keep like...
Every time I ask about the star catcher thing.
Okay, guys, guys, guys.
How do I do the...
What's the star catcher?
What does he do?
Stop flicking the stars.
Oh, does the stars stay?
I didn't know that.
Oh, it's stars.
Okay.
Okay, but like, I didn't know.
I'm so scared.
I'm so stressed out.
You don't understand.
Okay.
Come on.
Eat the stars.
Eat the stars and become yummy and big.
Eat the stars and become...
Yummy and big become so big for mommy.
Surely it's gonna be hungry, right?
Okay, now.
Alright, it's our economy.
Alright.
Oh, fuck, I'm sorry!
Please don't starve!
I can't help it!
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna put all of this.
Oh, no, he's gonna kill the...
Where is he?
Where is he gonna spawn?
Where is he...
Maybe he'll be hungry.
Okay.
Oh, my god, I should have...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We'll have the star catcher guy.
He'll be there.
He'll be okay.
He'll be so healthy.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
be so healthy so
think up your all your stars are to your left run all right
oh my god they're all so hungry okay guys there's so many
things to take right now i oh okay oh shit okay let's hope
what Oh, no.
Oh, no.
Eat that little one.
Eat that.
Oh, we're going to watch this little one die.
Ah!
Get in the corner!
Why you don't save him?
Because I want to make another star!
Oh, God.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I should have kept you on the job
Yeah Oh, please eat all of this
All right, we're fine.
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
Okay Okay, we made it we got Vert drop school just like but
doesn't need all nice Okay He does it are wearing a cloud
wearing a vert Vlad and Zorf.
I feel like we'll need Zorf.
We might need Zorf.
Wait, but that...
Zorf.
There we go.
Ver is kind of lame.
We'll see about that.
Don't worry, Ver.
They don't mean that.
I believe in you.
They might not believe in you, but I do.
Also, uh, Krik, they were the 10 gift of ships they could
thank you.
They don't believe, but I believe in you, right?
You're gonna do great.
I don't have to feed you.
All right.
I'll have to do my own fish economy now.
Okay, come on.
Come on, Clyde.
Clyde, come on.
Your entire job is to grab me coins.
And yeah, I'm the one still grabbing the coins.
Bro.
Bro, come on.
Pick up the slack.
My aim trainer is faster than you, bro.
Clyde!
Come on, Clyde.
I hide you based off a recommendation.
You're disappointing me right now, Clyde.
They recommended me to you.
Oh, now you got that.
Congratulations, you got that one coin.
What?
How?
How do I...
How hurt?
Oh, oh, I feed him.
Oh, he's a feeder.
oh i just all right i just feed him he's just the feeder guy
i get it
all right you'll be hungry right come on you're gonna be
hungry right
okay all right we're good
all right we're okay i wouldn't buy we'll get these guys big
no you want this you want no
Eat this, eat this, nice.
Okay, not you, not you, though.
Why can't you starve more?
Keep starving yourself.
Serve yourself now!
Now!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh, this is bad.
Oh my god, that didn't want you to eat it.
Not you!
No.
Oh my god.
Eat it.
Heal you.
No!
Not him!
It's okay.
It's like they never died.
It's like...
See, it's like they never died.
It's like, it's just like what my parents did.
Oh, not actually, it did.
Just like what your parents did.
Just buy another fish.
It's like they're...
It's like they were always here.
The raid's back.
They'll buy more food.
Alright.
Don't worry, they'll grow big and strong.
Maybe this guy will get hungry.
You can get...
No, no, do not get...
No, no, do not!
Do not!
Okay, there's why.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
We're okay.
Look at Ben go.
Oh, no.
Mani, this is so good.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I don't know who he ate.
Yeah.
If I make all of them big and strong and i can just spam the
the potion stuff
oh my stupid fish miss i saw you miss the okay one of you
has to be hungry come on yummy yummy no no not you come on
yummy yummy yummy yummy okay now we have three All right.
Oh, I keep asking.
Okay, now.
Well, it has to be yummy.
Yummy, yummy.
Okay, now I should be able to buy this guy.
And then I can...
That should be good.
Okay, come on.
Yummy, yummy.
Whoa.
Yeah!
Okay.
It's a lot of stars.
now.
Okay, and then... Oh, no.
Okay, I'll have six of these.
What?
It's like they never died.
Guys, it's like they never died.
It's okay.
We'll get there, guys.
We'll get there.
It's a...
It's a strata, alright?
We're gonna get there.
Oh,
what's going on?
What's going on?
Why do you have great lasers?
He's not...
It doesn't even kill him!
I forgot about that.
Glide!
Do something!
Oh
My guys, I don't know if I like this game
I can't tell yet
No, no, no the corner no All right, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's like nothing happened It's like nothing went wrong.
Alright.
There we go.
It's okay.
It's like nothing was lost.
Oh my god.
This is the slowest bird.
It's possible.
Alright.
Eat, eat, eat, eat.
Eat!
Take your meds!
Okay.
Just keep taking your meds, guys.
Remember to take your meds, everybody.
Okay.
More fish.
It might die anyway to Biggie.
Oh, speaking of Biggie, oh, here he comes!
But I just keep feeding spam.
I'll stay here.
Yes, stay here.
There you go.
Just stay there!
I think they're all big fish anyway, so one of them will eat
this, right?
I'm not another star catcher.
I mean, you have so many stars coming out right now.
Stars of the wazoo.
You know what?
Surely one of the big fish will eat this.
Oh, not you!
Okay, one of big fish will eat this.
Alright, nice.
I actually threw up another guppy in there.
Oh my god, Clyde, please.
I need you to do something with your life, Clyde.
Like, anything with your life.
Oh my god.
Okay, One more egg.
One more egg.
We're just in this corner.
Yeah.
I'm just... I'm just... Stay in your corner, Biggie!
Eh, that's fine.
We're getting there.
Oh, there's so many stars.
This might be the longest level.
Please don't die.
Please... I'm...
feeding you so much.
Oh, yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Oh, I'm there.
Get me out of this hellhole.
Rufus the fiddler crab.
Who's he gonna fiddle today?
The enemies you've lured to the bottom.
Your game has been saved.
All right.
Well, I'm always luring them to the bottom.
Okay, we're gonna get...
All right, Clyde is apparently good at late game.
So, I trust you, Clyde.
I don't know I should get Okay, we're gonna get Clyde,
Rufus, and Zorf.
All right.
We have a mission today, guys.
I believe in you, Rufus.
I'm gonna send them to the bottom.
And you go, shank him.
It's your entire mission.
It's your entire purpose in life.
Shank him.
All right, nice.
Another guppy.
All right.
I don't know if I'm making good progress.
I cannot tell.
I...
Now that's a knife.
I don't know if I'm doing good, guys.
I don't think I'm microing and macroing correctly.
I...
I actually don't think so.
My micro and macro might not be ideal.
from their fish in there the fish economy
okay type d detected oh guys guys guys guys stay out of the
bottom guys that's that's where danger is what
rufus it
just happened it just happened What happened to us?
Oh, no.
Rufus, you had one...
Can I click the rockets?
Guys, are the rockets clickable?
I can click the rocket.
Oh my god!
I've lost lives!
For no reason!
Lives were lost today and they did not have to they didn't
they didn't have to die
find another one i'm just gonna keep buying fishes and blame
rufus why didn't you intercept the rocket rufus millions of
lives are lost because of you you go back to bed filled with
trauma of a you could have saved we
got this Rufus teamwork okay
got this we'll add more fishies we need more we need more
wait will they kill my oh he's gonna kill my jellyfish soon
too I'm not jellyfish but what's his name the star catcher
Don't need more.
Just gotta keep making more.
We're gonna always make more.
Oh, you're all still so small!
Grow bigger!
Okay, wait.
I think.
Okay.
I don't want to throw the star potion yet.
Because I don't believe in myself.
Okay.
All right, where do you got?
Oh, okay.
Get in the corner.
Here we go.
You guys might be able to do star potion here.
Oh, you're so hungry.
Yeah, you're so hungry for me.
Come on.
You're so hungry too, right?
Yeah!
Oh, shit.
Don't, that's not what I want.
Come on, you're so hungry.
You're so hungry.
Yeah, become...
No!
And now we grab a star catcher, though.
We have, like, two.
That should be enough.
Good job, my little fishies.
Get big and strong for daddy.
Aren't you also...
No, that's you!
That's you!
We're on fish.
Well, now they're all big fish, so now I don't have to worry
as much now now that they're all big fish They can all like
one of them will eat this right?
Yeah, there we go.
So now we have two star catchers and I can get another one
of this and I'll grab another laser gun Okay, let's hope I
don't know if my star catcher is gonna live which is a
little concerning I don't know if they beat them up.
Okay, they don't.
That's good.
Okay, they live.
That's on you.
No.
Wanted to eat this.
No!
You're wasting my money!
We're good to go.
Should I put more?
You know what?
Fuck it.
This is the only way.
It'll grab another laser.
You know what?
Fuck it.
This is the only way.
Okay, just because I don't know if they're hungry or not.
We got increased production.
More fishies!
We have another star catcher.
We have so many stars going in.
Like, I feel like it's five.
Oh, I hope nobody's dying.
I...
That's my fear right now.
I hope none of the fishes are starving.
I can't tell.
Oh, this might be a little chaotic now.
What is this?
Okay, it's fine.
We killed them fast.
Okay, nice.
Keep eating for me.
Alright.
Good job.
Good job, guys, Clyde.
Good job, Clyde.
You know what?
You're right.
The guy that I recommend.
You know what?
You're all right, Clyde.
You are all right.
Now you're finally putting in the work, Clyde.
They're all big fish?
I can't tell.
I think so.
Which means I can throw another...
potion in here.
Maybe one of them will eat it.
We're almost there.
We're almost to the...
No, I'll put... Actually, I'll do another laser just in
case.
So I can kill them faster.
Production time!
Increase production!
I'm glad you got recommended for a company, Clyde.
It took you a while to get situated, but once you figured it
out, you know what?
You're part of the team.
Oh, thank God he's like aiming really far too.
That's really helpful.
Oh, I hope everybody is alive.
Okay, one more.
It's just all fishes.
I can't see my screen anymore.
It's all...
Yeah, I'm a fish mill.
More fish!
More fish for the factory farm!
You're all at another star catcher in here too.
I demand more!
I'm so hungry.
I came here to see fish.
Okay.
Oh, don't starve.
Don't starve.
Is everybody okay?
Are you all eating good for me?
Oh.
There we go.
Oh, I need one more.
It's okay.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Get out of my fish!
Of my fish factory!
It's my aquarium!
Only I can kill my fishes!
That's right.
Only I'm allowed to kill them.
More!
Until I...
Everything is just fish!
I can't see anything anymore.
It's just fish!
Yes!
it always it's just all fish jockey always has been no one
kills them for me i bring them into this world i take them
out there we go maryland the mermaid oh my gosh is this okay
for me to keep all right mermaids not no mermaids don't have
rights apparently Merlin song cheers up all the guppies in
the tank, making them drop coins faster.
Oh, okay.
Merlin, good.
I guess they'll make them drop coins faster.
Uh, well, dude.
Alright, Rufus.
I'm sorry.
But we're not gonna call you in today.
Sing for them, my mermaid.
Sing!
Oh, yeah, because they're half-fish.
They only have half the rights.
And voting isn't one of them.
Alright, let's see.
We're in a half-fish vote.
Or they want something stupid.
Like rights for fish.
Imagine that.
Oh, no, no, no.
Pretty calming now.
I have a big fish already.
Wait, that's fast.
I gotta eat fast.
This fish ate all the food.
Oh, what kind of monster?
Type D.
Okay, type D is fine.
It's not as bad.
The only issue is I just don't Rufus here anymore.
Just put him in the corner.
All right, now we have two big boys.
I just need to make him starve.
Nice.
No, no, no.
Yeah!
Starve for me, my little man.
Starve!
That's right.
Starve for your daddy.
Yes.
Is he starving yet?
He'll eat this.
Yes!
We maxed that out, which is what we needed.
We need this guy to starve now.
Man, I know you're so hungry.
Okay.
I forgot to upgrade this.
Okay, now we definitely need a star catcher.
Okay.
Where is he?
No, no, feed him, Zorf!
Feed him!
He's gonna die!
Spin food out!
Feed him!
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, there you go.
Fine.
Not scared at all.
Not that scared.
I was not that scared.
Wasn't even scared.
Now I can send in an army of new children.
all right
the new gen and now I can grab a star catcher too all right
the new generation is here I don't but um but um
all right I just need another girl big and strong come on my
little guy Yes, keep growing.
Yes.
Keep growing for me.
The future is now.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
It's raining money.
Alright, type D.
At least, like, this is, it's, like, not as hard as the ones
that swim.
Because you're on the floor.
Okay, I need you to get out of there.
Like, stay down there.
That's fine.
I need to increase my gun power, though, for sure.
Okay, we need more fishes.
My only solution.
Increase production.
Come on, grow up.
Come on.
Oh, Clyde!
It's okay for time!
Y'all work overtime!
You're not gonna see your kids and wife for a very long
time, Clyde.
I'm sure that one of these guys would be hungry, right?
Just never mind.
We're not hungry.
Alright.
10,000?
And we're going to make sure that all these guys grow up
before I send in the potions.
And then we'll grab more starcatchers after.
Okay.
Are they all big?
No, there's just this one guy that's still a grunt in the
family.
Oh, when they're glowing, it's so hard to tell if they're
hungry or not.
Okay, all right, it's fine, it's fine.
Everything's fine.
Come on, big fish, big fish, oh my big fish.
Okay.
All right, then I can.
I'm buying, I'll buy two.
and then laser upgrade and then this upgrade and then
another i think they're all big yeah they're all they're
almost all of them are all right nice and i can buy another
one it should be enough star catchers now we have a lot you
know what we'll make another one oh not you it's time
production increase
All right.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh, there's so many fishes.
What's going on?
Type G!
What was type G?
It's like we didn't lose anything.
It's like we never lost a fish, guys.
It's like we did it a whole lot.
Oh my god.
Clyde, I need you to work overtime.
You're never, you're not going to see your children's
graduations.
Oh my god, it's going to take fucking forever.
My sis, I had five more fish.
I'm sorry, you're going to have to miss your kid's wedding.
I'm sorry, Clyde.
It is business.
You're should have known when you sign the contract to work
for our team to work for our division you should have known
what you got yourself into
I trust I'm hell marrying this surely one of them will be so
hungry
surely nice okay we got another one oh no type deal Okay,
type T.
Type T is five.
There you go.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Surely one of them will eat this.
Is no one hungry?
I have another one, too.
I feel like we're going to need it.
Oh, they're so hungry.
I'm so sorry.
I can't tell anymore!
Okay.
Grab another one too.
I'm rich!
Oh, whoops.
Not me to... Whoa, I did not mean to steal the stars.
Alright, I think we might start starving soon.
You know what?
I believe.
Oh my god, there's so many diamonds.
I don't even know what to do with all these diamonds.
More fishes.
That's what I'm going to do.
Until I can't see anymore.
Okay, type D.
That's fine.
We can handle these.
The guy always aims at the one in the corner, too.
That's really helpful for me.
Oh my god.
hungry they don't know where to go they're all so hungry
okay one more we're so close to the end i'm just gonna keep
collecting money sing sing for me
oh keep eating keep eating i know you're all so hung no died
i can't tell there's too many fishes on my screen are not
special Wordsworth helps by shelling your baby and medium
guppies from hungry aliens.
Oh, okay.
That's actually very helpful.
Oh, medium guppies.
I don't care about that.
All right.
We gotta get for the... Yeah, the blues are good.
Nice.
932.
Yeah, not the large.
What's the point?
What's the point if it's not the big boys, you know?
Okay, Meryl was good.
Yeah, this whale is worthless.
Your life does not matter.
Okay, Zorath is clad.
These three have been doing God's work in my insane
aquarium.
We're not getting the snail.
We're not getting...
Stink... Was his name Stinky?
That guy...
That guy was like 90 years old, guys.
He was not efficient.
Back to the tank you go.
Clock in, clock out.
You're here forever.
I don't even know why he hasn't retired yet.
We had to force him out of the company.
He was planning on dying at his desk.
We were like, oh, we don't want a lawsuit in our hands
there.
We literally had to force him to retire.
Just for him to leave.
And then we got new Gen Clyde coming in.
Just graduated from Harvard.
And this is the best he could get.
With his degree.
We think he retired.
Just stopped showing up.
You know what?
What is approaching?
Enemy approaching.
There we go.
Yeah, wait.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, I didn't get any experience.
So this is the best you can do working in a sane aquarium.
He gets paid, like, $6 an hour.
I mean, all he does is collect money.
I think, like, you know, it's not that hard.
He just swims around collecting money.
Oh, nice.
One guppy catcher.
What's that?
Guys, what?
This looks very intimidating.
Guys, the guppy catcher looks very intimidating.
Seems like a very friendly working environment.
I know.
It catches.
If I had to guess, it catches.
Yes, but what does it do?
Alright, we'll see, I guess.
Oh, so...
Okay, but how many guppies does he eat?
No.
Is he gonna eat all my guppies?
If I...
I'm worried about that guy.
This catches guppies, don't he?
What else does he do?
away from my guppies.
No, no, no, no.
Get away.
I mean, I guess I'll try it.
Okay, but how big does he eat?
Like, how big of a guppy, though?
He's one of those, like, don't go down there.
Oh, he's coming.
He's coming.
Oh!
Don't worry.
Boom.
Guys, guys, guys.
Get out of there.
Don't go back in there why
would you go back in
yeah oh he's he's hung oh wait oh wait he wants oh wait
that's how he eats bro there's so many go bro eat one eat
one there we go eat one okay okay that's how i have to do it
i get it now oh that's confusing oh my god he ate both of
them Okay, well, I gotta keep making money, I guess.
He sends, I know he sends Beto's up.
Okay.
We're leaving the little shame corner.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, a turtle!
Seamore's presence makes all coins and diamonds drift at a
slower rate.
I don't think I need that.
That's just skill diff, honestly.
I think that's just skill diff.
I don't think I need him to drift slower.
Sumer is...
I mean, his name is Seymour.
Imagine naming your baby Seymour.
I'm sorry to all the Seymour's out there that are watching
me.
It's like you won your child if you're a 70-year-old man.
You make a good stump.
I heard they make really good seamhams, though.
Look at them fighting for that food.
Born to grow old.
Yeah.
Oh my god, that fish was camping.
He was so hungry.
Whoops.
Alright, slow and steady, guys.
Come on.
Zorf, come on.
Don't be a little bitch.
There's someone back up there.
all right oh my god are you stupid what's wrong with you go
back up there oh no not i don't remember what she was i'm
gonna grab this just in case it's a big boy oh my god it is
don't eat him no i said no no no
Oh, I'm back to two.
Whoa.
Oh, up.
Back to two, I go.
Back to raising them from...
Wow, you got a free guppy catcher.
Lucky.
It's strange that my guppy catcher disappeared.
god yeah give them the meds maybe they'll grow bigger yeah
we got to raise them when they're young okay they do grow
faster with the meds though thank god
i'm gonna try and actually okay we're just gonna keep
getting more fish at this point i feel like that's the only
way Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, okay, I have
more money now.
Come on, don't spawn near them.
Oh, you can eat that one, though.
It's fine.
He was just born.
He didn't matter that much to me.
He...
It's okay.
I have three more to replace him.
He just grew up.
He just came out of his mom's womb.
Okay, now this should be better.
Now I can spam this more.
Alright, I might be able to grab a guppy catcher soon.
Can you finally afford one?
Alright, there you go.
And then we'll have a guppy catcher.
We'll have more guppies in here.
Okay, so the guppy is hungry.
Not the big one, not the big one, though.
All right, little guys, little guys.
Just in case, there we go, yes.
All right, there we go.
Now we're making money, yes.
All right, oh, what's this?
We don't munch here.
Oh, so like, this will get...
Oh, my God, okay.
Okay, we'll grab this because we're going to need it.
Grab here, get down here, get down here.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
and then we'll grab more guppies and then we'll get another
guppy muncher and then from there we can have the beetle
muncher okay and then we'll grab more guppies because he
decided to eat another one uh he was very very hungry guys
you don't understand oh there's so many coming in
okay all right definitely grab more guppies because they're
eating more than I can produce.
I don't even know they're growing up anymore.
I can't tell.
Eh.
Don't get the beetle muncher.
And then...
Alright, this should be good.
We have a system.
Go eat the beetles!
We have a system in place.
Come on.
It's right there.
Are you blind?
Are you fucking blind?
is right okay it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine what
do you why have big eyes if you can't see that's all i'm
saying okay there you go it ain't hungry toky
i'm just saying why have big eyes
Oh my god, you are gonna starve.
Wait, I didn't mean that I He's like, okay, I guess I will
starve then I didn't mean that I mean actually starve
Okay Okay, I keep having the seven guppies because I don't
know if we're losing how many guppies we're losing right
now.
I can't tell.
No!
Okay, our guppie economy is a little tragic.
Oh, there's so many.
Okay, they got here.
Oh my god, they're eating so many, I can't tell!
How many guppies do I have left?
Okay.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Oh, they're eating so many.
I think I think I've refreshed my guppy economy.
Oh, get me out of this hell.
Get me.
Alright, drops bombs that blow up fish on contact.
It gives lots of damage.
Cash one clicked.
Hmm.
I don't know if this is useful.
But it gives a lot.
You know, I can click really fast.
Guys, I can click really, really fast.
Guys.
I can click really, really fast.
all right let's see how this goes there you go see guys
nothing to worry about i knew it i knew there was nothing to
worry about all right here we go
stand underneath him dad's like yeah she can yeah I seen it
I seen her click really really fast see he gave me a vouch
plus one vouch and you guys should not have yeah
no he was my biggest one he was actually my biggest one look
I got distracted don't stand here don't stand next to him
are you fucking oh you are you are p which one was p
what does he do get away get away from him get away get away
no
holy shit how much hp do you have
Oh, I didn't read Wait Oh Phone
blocked it
Blocked the text So I couldn't see I just see alien regains
health And I didn't see like My phone blocked the stop
Shooting What are you getting away?
It was true My phone actually blocked it.
I didn't see it.
It actually conveniently was at the place where it was like,
don't click on it.
It was true.
I swear.
Oh, I missed that.
Why is it three?
Kill it!
Three is a little...
Three might be a little and too little.
I wish I could have more than just...
Oh, I should have brought Clyde back.
I should have told him to come back in for work today.
There you go.
Oh.
These are all growing bigger now.
Oh my god, the fucking drive-by.
Oh, that was close.
Oh my god, please, please stop swimming!
Why are you swimming towards him?
Oh my god, you fucking idiot.
It is survival of the fittest at that point.
That is the survival of the...
You want to die.
Like, that guy, that fish...
Wanted to die.
He had a death wish.
Okay, there we go.
Oh.
Wait, he died.
Wait.
He ate my...
He ate my guppy catcher.
I just realized he's got it.
Okay, thank God.
He ate the crab?
He ate my guppy catcher?
I can't tell.
Like, what did he eat?
That's fucked up.
You mean you can eat... Oh my god.
Like this guy...
Like it's... He's already struggling, guys.
Come on.
Oh my god.
Guys, it was a mistake grabbing the fucking bomb, man.
It's actually a mistake having him in my party.
I was like, don't worry, I have fast reflexes.
And I remember that guy.
Not the right idea.
Oh my god, I think he ate a lot of the...
I can't tell.
Oh my god, stop surrounding him!
Oh my god!
Guys, we're not making money anytime soon.
We're not making any money.
Guys, we might just be a guppy economy.
We just...
We might just rely on the guppy economy at this rate.
Guys, I...
I don't know.
Alright.
We're just gonna...
We're just gonna focus all in on guppies.
All in!
Anyway.
All in on guppies, guys.
All in.
All right.
At least I saved his life there.
Don't worry.
When they start singing.
When the mermaid starts to sing.
Here we go.
See, I told you.
When the mermaid starts to sing, guys.
This is...
There we go.
Don't poop.
Okay, there we go.
All in.
Enough bird.
Yes, alright, there we go.
I should kill him a little faster.
Stay in this court.
Just stay in this court.
There we go.
Get up, get, get, leave, leave, leave, leave.
Oh, you just die.
Oh my god, I said leave.
I had such simple instructions for all of you.
Oh, I'm just glad.
Yeah.
It's fine.
We can sustain ourselves with the guppy economy.
It's very sustainable.
We're guppies.
We don't need anything else.
The guppy catchers, they'll just die anyway.
All in!
What?
Since we're all in in this.
It's fine.
More guppies.
Eventually, um, Clive would go so hard right now here.
It would actually.
Oh, okay, okay, let's just, let's hope.
Oh, let's log.
okay all right let's oh this is a little bit hard than i
thought we're gonna let these two fishes die i guess don't
worry we have their replacements okay maybe all in on the
guppies was not the right
Okay, I'll send two in.
Maybe that was a mistake.
Maybe I made a mistake there.
Okay, it's a lot faster now.
Who?
I died.
I can't tell.
There's too many guppies.
There.
It's okay.
We're making it to our first eight, guys.
We're getting there.
Oh, no.
I'll aim him to the top.
No, no.
He's going back down.
No!
No, there's so many over there!
Don't get away from them!
Okay.
Oh my god, first egg.
Our first egg upgrade.
I didn't think that was possible.
I...
I didn't think we would see the day.
The very first one.
Maybe another go...
Whoops, sorry.
Oh!
I can't...
I'm sorry, there's just...
There's so much to keep track of.
Where is Clyde when you need him?
Here.
We're five.
Alright.
think I think my fishes are happy maybe okay one more one
more we're almost there we're almost there oh where is he
gonna spot why now goodbye guppy fishes goodbye why are you
watching leave leave why did you have to watch
What was the point of watching?
What?
They're like, what's that?
What is that?
Who's that?
Who's this guy?
Is he fish?
The curiosity killed the fish.
Oh my god, I don't even know who that is.
So the fish investment was.
not it let's just say the guppy investment made it a lot
more worse
not my brightest ideas
okay oh my god get me out of here hey get me get me out of
here tracks guppies learning my way oh my god there we go
gumbo there we go i swear to I swear to God, Gumball fucking
lures them into people.
I swear to God, Gumball.
I swear to God.
All right.
Here we go.
I swear to God, Gumball.
Your one job is to make sure they're not in...
They're lured away from the aliens.
Fuck, I forgot Clyde.
You're right.
Okay.
Alright, let's get Clyde.
I want Clyde.
Clyde, we need a Clyde there.
Okay.
Clyde with the mermaid.
Here we go.
The only issues I have to feed them myself now.
Is it always three?
Also, sure.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa there.
Whoa there, little guy.
You gotta do that.
of a mermaid?
You guys aren't in the same level.
You're...
What's that word?
Where she's like too good for...
Where she's like below her standards.
Oh yeah.
Bro, you're out of her league, bro.
You're so out of her league.
Out of his league.
Let's try to think of the super chat thing you think.
I don't know if anything will help.
Guys, my phone blocked the text, guys.
I swear.
Type new.
Which one was type new?
Oh my god, he's actually doing it.
What the fuck am I playing, Pong?
I'm fucking playing Pong right now.
Okay.
Okay, thank God he actually lured them away.
What the hell is going on?
Playing ping pong with the fucking fish.
With the alien.
Gumbau, a hero.
Talk about your story for years to come.
I'm gonna have to hand feed my fishes.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna invest in more.
I'll have to anyway.
Come on.
Big and strong for me little guys.
What do I do with these fishes after like each level?
Do I just...
I dumped it back into the ocean and go again.
Like, I'm done playing with you.
I need new fishes in my life.
I think I can get one of these guys now.
I love the little drive-by.
Okay, what about this guy, though?
Alright, nice.
Oh, at least he doesn't do anything with the guppy guy.
There's a lot of things.
I think I can add a lot more of these guys and then every
time he eats two one I'll put two in just to keep the cycle
going I'll grab another guppy guy all right and then two
sorry three oh okay another two Keep them going.
Make sure we have the economy for this.
Two.
So we're always positive, guys.
Oh, that's a lot.
I'm another one of that.
Another one of this guys, too.
Okay, now I need to save up.
I'm gonna try and save up for the big boys.
Oh my god, please, please, I die.
Nice.
I'm gonna save up for the big boys now.
Come on, we're so close to 2000!
Okay, we're here.
All right, now we can start getting pros.
Nice.
and grab some more guppies because I don't know if they're
living I don't know how many eating now I've lost count oh
my god 10,000 okay, it's fine, it's fine
might be able to grab two of these guys then then we'll just
we'll just hope for the best we're just hoping for the best
oh my god, glad, glad Keep doing your job.
Keep doing job.
God's work, man.
Oh, are they being fed?
I can't tell.
Ooh, this way, this way.
I should upgrade the lasers now.
Oh, he does not care.
Oh, I hear so many puppies dying.
Oh, there's so many dead guppies right now.
We need to make sure the guppy ratio is sustainable.
We need to not overfeed.
Overfish.
All right, we got first egg.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, whoops.
Let's hope that didn't starve them.
Oh, it's just hog boys.
God, are you breaking them
up?
Oh, they're all so hungry.
I'm 500 guppy.
I think I might need another one.
I think I might need more.
I think I need to control the guppy population right now.
I think I messed up, guys.
I might have messed up a little.
We gotta control the guppy population.
AHHHHH!
My dad, please, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I've burned a nice shot.
Oh, the beetle eaters die!
Please!
Yes, I have to!
I might have have too much copies guys.
I might have messed up.
I potentially might have messed up.
Okay.
We're gonna get another one of these guys.
Oh no.
Oh,
no, I haven't...
It's okay, we're almost there.
We just...
Please don't start.
Please do not start.
Please do not stop.
I have more food coming in.
Just keep eating.
I don't know who's starving.
I can't die!
guy in this corner in this corner there you go
oh my god everybody's diving oh my god they got freedom
freedom freedom info that helps you better come back and
keeps your fish fed okay well it keeps my fish fed so i
don't know i feel like what are you even i don't want to
okay glad mirrored go all right we'll do one more around
we'll do one more round all
right here we go
i don't know about i don't know i don't know if i like the
cuppy kind i don't know if the guppy kind of music guys guys
i think i had too much cupies i definitely didn't Not
control the population very well.
Oh, that fish isn't starving.
Can't tell.
He's very into gumbo.
He's, like, shooting his shot everywhere.
Are you okay?
Are you...
Alright.
Eat, little guys.
Eat.
Eat so you can make me money.
That's your only purpose.
The guppy inflation.
Yeah.
I might have, like, poured in, like, 8 trillion guppies into
the ocean hoping everything will be fine might have inflated
the guppy dollar a little bit okay type p i think that was
one i hated right
yep no i'm i'm no we're just gonna stop it here we're I
don't really want to deal with the octopus.
We're going to stop it here.
I'm like, type Pete, yeah, that's, I'm good.
I'm good.
That was fun, though.
It was a tactical retreat, guys.
A tactical retreat.
That was a, okay, I don't, okay, I have fun is such a, fun
might not be the right word.
That was, I didn't realize how stressed, who would have
thought, a game with the word, a game with the word insane
in it was pretty stressful.
It might have been a very stressful experience, Michael, and
managing all of that.
But I did, I did have fun.
yeah it was like it's like you know what don't keep let's
give you more stress in life today
uh fun ball thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um thank you guys for hanging out with me we do have another
for member goons we do have another stream tonight where
we'll be visiting the dragon power world server again um
we're gonna be checking it out seeing the progress My
students at Doakford University have in Spain in competitive
battling.
So we'll see that.
Thank you guys all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time.
We're tonight, everyone.
Tomorrow is the Onimusha release.
We will be giving away five game codes for Onimusha, the
newest Onimusha game.
So if you guys want a game called yourself, I'll be giving
it away at the end of the stream provided by MSI.
You guys know the routine.
We're going to be playing it.
The giveaway will be at the end of the stream.
Now I'm just going to pull it out from the chat and just go
do the exclamation enter to enter the giveaway.
And you have to message, instead of mentioning Doki merch,
my manager has a Twitter now.
So you just have to message my manager to claim your code.
Anyway, guys, I'll see you guys later, everybody.
See you guys tomorrow night for the Onimusha release launch.
Bye guys.
Bye.